what a whirlwind couple of days for the
Democrats their mood's been all over the
place kind of a whiplash of emotions
well after their wins in Kentucky and
Virginia in Ohio MSNBC panels were
oozing excitement and liberals were
proclaiming that Biden was back baby
campaign officials said it's we're
golden now but now you can almost feel
their heart palpitations because third-
party Challengers aren't dropping out of
the race more are jumping in it's not
just Bobby Kennedy Jr it's and Joe
Mansion it's Cornell West and Jill Stein
that takes the potential threshold of
third party candidates to an
unprecedented level if you have two
thirdparty Challengers that get on the
ballot in many of these really really
tight States it could cause a problem
for the president when you do the
Electoral math what happens more often
than not with a No Labels candidacy uh
is that Donald Trump gets elected to the
White House will be no country if we
don't have historic in Epic voting in
2024 Doug scared and those fears are not
without Merit though because first in
2020 remember just 44,000 votes in
Georgia Arizona and Wisconsin 44,000
separated Biden and Trump from a tie in
the Electoral College and second you
know money's pouring in from Rich donors
who think Biden's on the brink and I'm
not talking brink of
Victory Mansion is affiliated with a
group called No Labels that is exploring
a Centrist Unity ticket in 2024 they are
already on the presidential ballot in 12
States including several key
Battlegrounds former house Speaker Nancy
Pelosi has called No Labels perilous to
democracy Biden has called their efforts
a
mistake I bet and then this from the
folks at Puck some are Whispering about
the potential for a brokered convention
next summer when Biden could be
convinced by party leader leaders people
he respects like Obama kurn Nancy Pelosi
to step down if his numbers are still
dismal I don't think that's going to
happen but I say if these folks are too
pessimistic Joe Biden look I think he's
getting warmed up I'm looking on the
positive side here and there's a lot of
good news out there like he's almost
able to dress
himself
[Music]
that's the guy who's going to be sitting
across the table from China's president
xiin pin in less than a week and all
indications are that Biden is preparing
to begin a new era of capitulation
excuse me um cooperation with China now
we know the complicated negotiations of
basically been done by Biden's crack
negotiators over the past six months or
so he's just there for the photo op but
we know this what's going to come out of
this will be good for China and terrible
for us because with Biden poised to give
up key us leverage probably the major
tariffs on Chinese Imports XE knows that
he can promise and never deliver oh
we're going to help you Joe on climate
change yeah right is China prepared to
blow up all the hundreds of new C fired
plants they built over the past few
years is never going to happen but they
will dominate EV manufacturing and put
our car companies out of business
they'll do that hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else